. Let's go next to our caller from the five
zero eight area code, five away. What's your
name? Where are you calling from?
Hello? Can you hear me? Yes, I can. Who's
this?
Yes, I am. Out of four more, sir. And I want
to start off by saying that are a big fan
of your show for many for like 10 years now.
Thank you. It's just for the past couple of
years, I have been quite disappointed with
your Russia investigation coverage. You really,
too. You don't seem to put. You don't seem
to put out there to your viewers counteracting
evidence that discredits a lot of this stuff.
The Russia gate narrative that's been pushed
by the Democratic Party. I'm on the left.
You know, I hate Trump. I just I just think
it's for the past couple of years. This is
like a bit of conspiracy theory. That's not
really based on a lot of facts.
OK, so, Adam, can we. Let's slow down, though,
because you're saying a lot and we want to
make this a conversation. What specific assertion
have I made that was incorrect?
Well. Well, you use your last word, Russia
video was about that. It's not a hoax that
it's. That it's it's not because of some information
that came out about Paul Manafort. I mean,
is a dead tie investigation was started fraudulently?
No. So, Adam, let's let's let's just deal
with that. So the the the recent video was
an analysis of a report that was put out by
the Senate Select Committee headed up by a
Republican, Richard Burr, which confirmed
most of the initial suspicions about interactions
between the Trump campaign and Russia in the
time leading up to the election. Now for you
to say what you. OK, go ahead.
Yes. Yes. So with Paul Manafort. And kill
him. Kill him, Nick. Right.
That's that's one of dozens of components.
Yes.
What way did you know what Paul Manafort was
doing in Ukraine?
He was doing a lot of different things over
a long period of time. But I I don't know
which ones which things you're talking about
and how the relevant to what's in the report.
Well, it is relevant because there's a narrative
out there that that Paul Manafort in Kelam
network like work that we're trying to put
its bidding or defending the quote.
Hold on, Adam. Adam, hold on a second. Did
I say that or what are you responding to right
now? Because I don't say that in the clip
you just mentioned to me. What I say in the
clip is Reid, the Senate Select Committee
report, and you will see that if your expectation
was Trump and Putin are going to get caught
on video colluding, that obviously did not
happen. And it's not what the outcome is going
to be. But if you look at the regular connections
and interactions between the Trump campaign
and Russians, they are confirmed by the report.
Now, you can disagree with the report, but
that's not me, right? I'm just telling you
what's in the report.
You don't like buy one. What I want counteracting
is your assertion that it's proves that's
not a hoax.
Of course, it's not over. So now how would
it be a hoax when you've seen countless arrests
and essentially everything that was seriously
alleged with evidence proven either in the
Mueller report or in the Senate select report?
If you're trying to cartoon ify the claim,
if you're trying to say, listen, David, you
were expecting Trump and Putin to get caught
in bed together colluding and for Trump to
be removed, then I would say I never said
that. I don't know who was saying that, but
maybe you should talk to them. But did you.
It sounds like you're saying it was a hoax
when every serious investigation has turned
out that it was not a hoax. Now, if you're
saying does it matter if you're saying does
it? Is it relevant to Trump's reelection or
whatever? I'm probably right there with you,
but to say it was a hoax seems completely
without evidence.
Well, I'm not I'm not I'm not saying it's
I'm not saying that the investigation itself
is just me. It's just what I'm saying is that
you do that with Paul Manafort and Kim killable
Nick. It does. So what if you had connections
with some Russian people killing Nick? You
want the State Department intel source with
this, OK? That was one hundred pages that
that might. That Mueller himself had that
described kill him, Nick, at the sensitive
intelligence source for the U.S. State Department.
Right. But it was but it was perhaps campaign
chairman who was briefing him on the campaign.
It was not those were not in who. So then
that would be an argument for American intelligence
to be dealing with him in some way. And if
you want to claim that they should have been,
then, you know, go ahead and talk about that.
But that has nothing to do with Paul Manafort
and the propriety of that interaction.
They were business partners saying it was
that it wasn't. So, of course, they're going
to communicate it. There's also my big problem
with this is Russia narrative is that it's
not based on reality people. People are using
it to describe Trump. That's a puppet of Russia.
But, Adam, hold on a second. Hold on a second.
Hold on a second. Who is doing that? Because
this is not even an issue. I mean, on my program,
this hasn't even been an issue for for like
a year and a half at this point. And we're
focused on whether we want to vote for Joe
Biden or Donald Trump and the failed handling
of Corona virus. I mean, you seem so wrapped
up in Paul Manafort and stories from a year
and a half ago. Who's talking about this now?
Who's making this the issue for the election?
Like, what do you try to do? Are you trying
to get me to say I was wrong about everything?
Fine. Specific claims I was wrong about then.
But so far you're not listening to things
I haven't even said.
I'm not sick. I'm not I'm not here to own
you. I'm a fan of yours.
I get it. But you said you're disappointed
in my coverage, and so far you've only listed
things. Adam, hold on. You've listed things
that I've not said as why you're disappointed
with me.
No, I said I'm disappointed that you have
it push back on this. A lot of the calls you
have pushed back, a lot of stuff like Bill
at Wal-Mart, anti-Semitism and prove it.
David. Women March. I agree with you on those.
It's just that in here you have a blind spot
because there's a lot of facts that just don't
add up to what?
Okay, so that's what I'm saying. Tell me tell
me what I've rupi tell me what I've heard.
I'm fine. All right, Adam, I got you. I appreciate
the phone call.
OK. And he hung up. Very good. I mean, it's
like what? So, OK. I just don't know where
to go with that. I really don't. Let's take
a quick break. If you're holding, don't hang
up, because we will be right back on the phones
momentarily.